[Music]
[Music]
hey
you guys i started like a minute early
because i wanted
before pookie decided to jump off with
jobs she's being good
yeah she's been sitting there a really
long time looking at her
getting mittens coming down yeah that's
why i call them rickett
hanging around there well hey you guys
nice to see you once again what the
hell's today it's monday that's right
yeah i was talking to assad
on um messenger there some private
messages talking about the damn new ufo
stuff that's coming out
oh new york times yeah see he's up in
saudi arabia he
and he he knows about you know my
granddad working for mcdonald
for granted aerospace down for the
shaw's air force in iran back in the 70s
yeah and that's when that damn tehran
ufo sighting happened
and he was working for the company they
came down and asked
if there was any kind of special because
they picked it up on a spy satellite
us government yeah it was a it was an
intelligence agency they
they went to grumman down there in the
tehran air
area that was helping build that air
force full of f-14s
and they asked if we were working on
anything secret or they i said we
should i would never work for gum gram
they asked if they were working on
anything secret they picked up something
they showed what it was it was the
satellite sensors picked something up
moving in at about mach 9. i think it
was mach 9 mach 10
and they picked it up through a spy
satellite and at that same location the
same area
the um iranian f-14s were engaging
lights in the sky that shot a little
light ball went down to the ground it
lit up the ground
and it was just this big pulsating light
that kept jamming their systems it
wasn't a
an earth aircraft it was some kind of
craft
they'd put it down as an unexplained
phenomenon
yeah i guess they would it's like you
don't know what the fun explain
phenomena it moved away
it moved out it was huge it was the size
of a damn 737's there's a
like an airliner and it moved away you
know mach 10 plus
yeah no anyway there's a bunch of stuff
going to be
released they're saying right now
pentagon's saying there's a bunch more
ufo stuff that they're that they're
willing to talk about
and it's stuff that came from spy
satellites they're seeing
unexplained phenomenon telling you they
know
come on aliens they don't know what it
is quit [ __ ] around
they don't know what it is but they know
it's not it's not
military stuff just land it'll be fine
they're [ __ ] some kind of drone
[Laughter]
you know we assume
we're waiting for more people to show up
we assume that um
spaceship with biological organisms in
it
i think that's highly unlikely it's
going to be something more like the damn
monolith from 2001
you know yeah it's going to be like that
it's going to be some kind of a
non-biological intelligence that's
immortal
can travel the [ __ ] gulfs of [ __ ]
space
it doesn't matter it doesn't have to go
faster than light because it doesn't it
lives so long
it doesn't care that it takes 10 000
years to get anywhere there's nothing
for it
you know what i mean yeah it would only
matter if you were biological
that's true so it's something
post-biological
they're just watching us probably we're
probably in their territory
yeah they're just like i said we're just
like the game preserve yeah
stopping by and make sure we're not
causing any trouble well probably what
it is is they're like well eventually
they'll make ai and that will evolve
into something like us and we'll talk
with that
yeah we're like we don't want to talk to
those losers yeah
probably just a normal part of the
evolution you start off biological
and then you start transcending
biological you downloading your soul
into a [ __ ] soul internet and then
then you just become and and
immortal like that thing out of 2001
yeah it's going to be like that look at
this he got that right
i believe that that's probably anything
traveling the gulf of space is going to
be like that monolith
yeah yeah messing with their little
beans
flying saucers with little people in
them and little biological entities and
[ __ ] that's
that's a 1950s concept that's not how
technology's gonna go
yeah well they didn't know about yeah
they were just pulling stuff right out
their ass
yeah i can't believe pookie's been
sitting there for this long oh yeah
she's
she's enjoying enjoying the show pokey
yeah she's like hey i'm on
everybody's looking at me we saw a real
good movie last night
by the same dude who did sicario and
that
yeah that's the thing it's like i didn't
really know about um because when louie
sent us
wind river and we watched that and i
really liked that and then you know you
we had sicario also
i don't know if he made sicario too
but sicario one was pretty yeah maybe
even though two was better than one
yeah sicario was still good i haven't
seen the second one yeah the second one
was even better
but um but yeah so i didn't even know
this was like kind of like a loose
trilogy or anything like that and then
when somebody said it was probably louie
actually said oh you should totally
watch
hell or high water and then when i was
on hulu a day or two ago
looking for some new movies to watch i'm
like hey they have helen hi
right there on hulu we watched it it was
an excellent movie man it was so
so good i can't believe i missed it it
came out back in 2016
and it's like this just shows how
closely i followed [ __ ] even like four
years ago
this was actually nominated for like a
[ __ ] ton of golden globes and a [ __ ] ton
of oscars
and um the uh i guess the script for it
which was called
uh comancheria or something like that um
it was kind of going around hollywood
you know how they have that thing if you
know anything about hollywood like
screenplays and stuff they have a thing
called the blacklist
which is kind of like the 10 uh most
popular scripts that haven't been made
yet
um and you know that that are going
around and everybody's trying to get
them made because they're you know the
most popular ones this one was like on
the top of that like for 2015 i think
so yeah this was actually written by
taylor sheridan the same guy that wrote
uh you know like we said sicario and
wind river
he didn't direct it though um the
director was david mckenzie who's a
scottish fella so um but the writer was
the same and i think that you can tell
yeah you can tell the right the writing
is excellent you know what i think the
best thing about this i love to win
river but i think i like this one
slightly better
um the cool thing about this one i think
is that the characters in this
are so [ __ ] great like every single
character in this
is a really good compelling character
you're rooting for the bad guys and the
good guys they're all kind of good guys
yeah everyone's sympathetic everyone's
sympathetic even though they're they're
killing each other except for that
douche in the green car at the gas
station that dude was not sympathetic
yeah right and he got his ass beat
and rightfully so but yeah like so yeah
so you're
kind of rooting for the cop characters
and you're kind of rooting for the bank
robber characters
because okay so if you don't know like
what this movie is about
it's basically they call it a neo
western which i guess it is
it's um supposed to be set in east texas
although i think they actually shot it
in new mexico but you know whatever
close enough
um and it's these two brothers uh toby
and tanner
now tanner has just gotten out of prison
and uh toby has an ex-wife and a couple
of teenage sons
and they decide that they're going to
start robinson banks now
um i'm not really i guess on the on the
um
you know description of the movie it
says why they're robbing the banks
because
you can kind of sympathize with the
reason that they're robbing the banks
it's not just like they're robbing the
banks because they want to you spend it
all on hookers and blow
they actually do have a good reason for
needing the money what i like about this
movie hold on let me interject a little
bit
if you like old star wars and the
mandalorian
then you'll like this writer that did
these three movies because
mandalorian in star wars when it's
written well is a
is basically ripoffs of these kind of
movies
these are frontier frontier tales
westerns
yeah and this guy does a really good job
at capturing
this the american situation in the
southwest and in the south
that's where a lot of this stuff takes
place yeah that are kind of like remote
areas
or areas that are kind of like forgotten
it's a totally
different world compared to say
new york california or europe it's
totally different
it is like a star wars [ __ ] moss
iceland type
situation in a lot of these places even
though it's a modern civilization you
know what i mean you have
shopping malls and [ __ ] like that
but most of america in that air in that
area is a bunch of it's a system of
or a network of dead towns yeah
and which you really see a lot of yeah
and that's the frontier when you think
about it
and uh they're these guys are on a
campaign of robbery
bank robbery going through these dead
towns they're targeting a specific bag
because they got reason to and
it's not easy because like i said this
is in the south the like this
this is happening in texas and where
arkansas
texas and oklahoma texas well oklahoma
that's where they go they go over the
border into oklahoma to like launder the
money like at the casino or whatever
it would and you're not going to be able
to just go into these little towns and
start robbing banks and get away with it
man
it's pretty accurate yeah the locals get
involved
which this locals get involved and
there's other that happens a lot
because they're carrying guns and [ __ ]
and uh
which that's accurate there's a lot of
[ __ ] that goes on in these small areas
it never makes national news
because it doesn't fit into the
narrative that the national news
but in the local news it'll tell you
[ __ ]
straight out of the whole west man
basically posses form and guys are
helping the cops and
just people in this on the spot on the
scene trying to stop a bank robbery and
you're just a random dude with a gun
all that [ __ ] happens you know it's just
it's a good story
real good i mean should we should we
spoil why they're robbing the banks or
should we not i don't even know
yeah i'm not saying but they do actually
have like a good like a sympathetic
reason
robbing the banks they got a grudge
against the bank but like i said
understandably and a lot of people have
a grudge against the bank it's talked
about
in the story you know um
there's also a lot of uh references to
the indian
um uh casinos they go to the casinos on
the indian land
uh there's a lot of that stuff going
which i i mentioned that in earlier
shows
which that's a that's a pretty cool
phenomenon i've been to many of them
and then what happens on those
reservation casinos
it's like something out of damn star
wars it is
but like i said the i think the best
thing about this movie the characters
are amazing i really really like the
fact that you can totally sympathize
with the brothers even though they're
doing something illegal technically
um but you can totally sympathize for
their reason for doing it the
interplay between them it's uh chris
pine and ben foster play the brothers
and uh the interplay between them is
great i think the best my favorite part
of the movie was the interplay between
jeff bridges character he's like the
sheriff or the
ranger or whatever and his partner who's
like half native american and half
mexican
yeah and uh they just like they drive
each other they just bust
each other's balls like all the time
yeah there's kind of a tonto
lone ranger [ __ ] quality to it but
they're also just busting each other's
balls through the whole [ __ ] movie
and it's hilarious and even like a bunch
of the side characters are hilarious
like that really cranky like waitress
yeah that one place where the cops get
to it's like the [ __ ] the t-bone
grill or whatever it's called and it's
like they only have one thing and
she's like really really crabby yeah and
then um
just in this movie it's like actually
because i saw you know
wind river which had some moments of
levity in it like some kind of funny
moments in it particularly toward the
end
but so i i guess i wasn't prepared for
how funny this movie was gonna be
like and all of the humor pretty much
comes from
the interactions between the characters
i mean it's just and the situations that
they get themselves into
well they're like regular guys but yeah
they're regular guys for the area
yeah yeah they wouldn't be regular guys
for say like new york or boston
you know but they're regular for the
southwest and
texans you know dude and uh they're wild
asses
it's [ __ ] funny though yeah well it's
just in like when they're first like
robbing the banks because they
their plan is they want to like stick to
like this one
particular bank because they have a
garage against that bank in particular
and you know probably intelligently they
want to stick to like really
small branches like in really small
towns so that's not you know they don't
want to get the fans involved right so
and they're not stealing like huge
amounts at one time because like i said
they don't want to trigger like fbi or
anything like that the bank robbers the
two guys are brothers and
they're cow pokes which yeah cowboys
yeah they do that's what they did for a
living
yeah they grew up like a ranch yeah and
so they got cowpoked skills
you know they can they're good they're
pretty good with guns uh
they're they're not real good at robbery
it takes them a while
you just gotta watch oh there's a steep
learning curve with that you know what i
mean
[Laughter]
and um but they had a good plan they had
a real good point it did actually end up
being a headline it had a lot of good
elements to the story there was heroism
on both sides self-sacrifice on both
sides
uh there was a conflicting missions and
the conflicting values
but both sides were kind of like
in a way kind of good guys yeah no no
the robbers were not they were good guys
they were committing crimes which you're
not supposed to do that and people were
getting killed
all right yeah so that's not so good um
i would argue that the one brother
tanner um he did most of that was his
kind of emotion
in a way you just gotta see the the
it's it's an old west story it's pretty
much
not to be judged by the moral systems of
outsiders
it it yeah it's
it's kind of a southern thing but like i
said i really did love
like not only all the characters at the
middle of the in the middle of the story
but also
all the side characters like the
waitress of the thing like the first
um yeah at the first bank that they rob
like that woman that they
you know they come in there and it's
like they're kind of they can't believe
they're robbing a place you're like
you're out in this place
it's like what the hell it's like you
know and it's like you got in here
before
the safe is even open do you even know
what you're doing and she was just like
she was kind of busted their chops too
yeah she's like look if you leave now
all you'll be guilty of is being stupid
and you had a pretty fat girl waitress
that didn't want to rat him out
because they left her 200 dollars left
her too so she didn't want to rat him
out yeah
cool yeah she thought they were cute and
she didn't want to tell lama
well and the cop too was like well we
need that money because it's evidence
and she was like yeah no that's like
half my mortgage
payment you're not getting anything was
[ __ ] accurate for the region
they go into a place called the t-bone
cafe and really the only thing on the
menu is [ __ ] t-bone sticks
and she just throws it in a couple of
times you don't you're not really
ordering she's telling you what you're
gonna get
and then you i love that you tell her
what you don't want i like i love that
i don't want the green beads
oh no look at that [ __ ] you killed baby
we got that [ __ ] on video
we're going to use that at her trial
okay that's
evidence but did she run away
she's like oh [ __ ] she's trying to smell
it she's smelling she's smelling uh
[ __ ] grosgu going is it dead did i
kill it you
killed rogue i told you no oh pokey
she's like she's looking guilty i didn't
mean
oh my god i can't believe she did that
she's like well it worked you guys are
paying attention to how yeah
tammy's like pookie she's so crazy
gramster's hammer says my favorite line
was soccer anything a five-year-old can
do isn't a sport
yeah all the [ __ ] about like jeff
bridges partner like putting the [ __ ]
um what do you call them like the radio
preachers on and like watching the [ __ ]
on tv and every day and they were like
giving each other [ __ ] about that that
was all kind of all kinds of good stuff
i mean so so funny it was an accurate
movie
and it was just i mean like everything
about this movie i just loved everything
about this baby they're like american
the cinematography was gorgeous um the
characters were all
memorable and they were all funny there
was just like funny [ __ ] it was tragic
[ __ ]
and it's just and the edit was really
really good it was like really really
tightly edited it didn't have
any any fat on it any filler any
anything like that
yeah and i also like how um they did the
uh the whole cowboys and indian
parallels yeah that's there's a big
theme of that that there wasn't much
that there wasn't really any difference
uh between the two um there was the same
kind of moral system
um like
they actually say it in a certain ways
throughout the movie
and then at the end one of the bank
robbers
basically starts doing indian stuff but
he's doing it a cowboy way basically
singing his own death song
and that song was an irish cow poke song
yeah
you remember yeah because he knew he was
gonna die
yeah he was giving up his life and then
um and he was
uh then he's he said that that this all
made him a comanche
because he'll come and he's like imagine
we're the enemies of
everyone yeah so yeah there's a scene in
the casino
it which like i said i guess that was
kind of like a theme because the
original
uh the original title of this was
comancheria comancheria i guess
we'll pronounce it but this is a
scottish director
it is yeah well he knew how to ill she
knew how to tell an american story
i was watching another review of this
and uh somebody said man it's really
interesting to see
a european director um and how they
they they don't shoot the you know the
u.s
like landscapes the same way an american
director would maybe because they
see the the oddities in it probably
that's
yeah i think that's what it is they take
it and they don't
yeah maybe that's what it is yeah but i
really really did like the
cinematography and i mean like i said
when we talked about wind river the
cinematography and that was gorgeous too
that was like mostly that was all
snow and [ __ ] like that and this is like
all desert and shitty looking
uh towns that nobody lives in like with
empty streets and
crappy like billboards everywhere and
[ __ ] like that
but it's just like yeah i just i loved
everything about this movie and i'm
amazed that it took me this long to get
to it
and that i didn't even realize that it
had been nominated it got nominated for
so many awards
that it has it not only has its own
wikipedia page about the movie
but it has a wikipedia page just for all
the awards it got nominated for
so that's how many it got nominated for
and like i said i think i know i feel
bad
[Laughter]
she's mad because grogu is like cuter
than me i'm gonna
knock her over knock him over is it a
boy or a girl i can't sit there wagging
[Laughter]
she was laying there next to it on her
back did you see it no i didn't see that
right next to it
[Laughter]
this morning well this morning i came in
here to get my um
you know to get my phone and my
headphones like before i went on my hike
or whatever
and when i came back out into the living
room it was kind of dark this morning so
it's kind of rainy
and i noticed she was laying on her back
like right in the middle of the living
room floor
like she's just like laying there going
hey you can't avoid me
yeah that's so likely hopefully she's
such a [ __ ] goofball
so um i think there's we pretty much
wrapped it up huh yeah we did is it
excellent yeah if you haven't seen it
see it it's on hulu i'm sure you can get
it on other streaming services as well
but that's uh
you got hulu you know you can see it for
free yeah i mean you know
well worth it real good movie i was it's
just so weird that
it was just like this weird kismet that
we just did wind river and then i was
just
like hey just another one i gotta get on
blu-ray
yeah definitely all three of them yeah
oh and i and i should say too that uh
nick cave and warren ellis also did the
score for this one yeah
and it was lovely there is a lot of um
country music in this too
yeah more not not so much country more
like western yeah
you know i mean in the nick cave style
western yeah
yeah although there's they do sing some
country music
yeah yeah it is they played on the radio
that's what i was saying that's what i
was referring to
hammer said my favorite scene was the
bad boy and the green charger who got
his ass yeah yeah
yeah i i enjoyed that very much also um
because that dude was such a douche and
it's like
he's gone on a wrong dude the whole
thing it's just like it see
it was so texas although they do this
[ __ ] in florida too but it's like
was just like look i'm just this douche
in a [ __ ] flashy car and they just
pull up and like just start trouble for
no reason whatsoever
yeah yeah they [ __ ] just say what
you're looking at you badass
like i like dude i wasn't looking at
anything i had sunglasses on
he wasn't checking his six though that
dude [ __ ] another dude walked up
right behind him just beat the [ __ ] out
of him
well yeah because i mean after his gun
let's do
just so it fun this moment like i said
it was like way
funnier than it was not a comedy but it
had a lot of like funny moments like
that where it's like
because it's kind of realistic yeah but
yeah it was realistic but
like in a funny guy tried to grandstand
but that's not the way it went he wasn't
watching right behind him
[ __ ] took his [ __ ] [ __ ] through it
went around the other side of the card
beat up beat the other dude's ass no no
no no he was in the wrong he was like
he had a company he had to come yeah
[Laughter]
i'm like if only that happened more in
real life yeah if you
have people stop acting that way it does
happen it's just
you don't see it i guess it happens
that was just that and the [ __ ]
scenes in the
the scene in the diner with that like
cranky old waitress with the t-bone i
mean that [ __ ] i died laughing
at that that yeah that was bringing back
memories i mean that's
that's the way a lot of restaurants
little small mom paul restaurants are
like that in mississippi
especially a little like soul food
restaurants around on the coast there's
nothing
to go to it's kind of like that it was
uh
owned by this old black lady and uh she
made breakfast lunch and dinner and she
made it
each one of them once so it's kind of
like a buffet
yeah you walked up there and she made a
plate for you yeah i mean
it's like she didn't ask you she didn't
ask you what you wanted she's just like
here this is what you're having that's
what you have
well that the thing is the reason why i
went there is because you could have a
giant plate of grit [ __ ] fantastic
home-cooked meal for like 4.99 okay yeah
so wouldn't you go yeah well [ __ ] yeah
yeah and it was all stuff that
being southern ud yeah and it was
nothing unusual
it was all just traditional southern
stuff and you never knew what it was
going to be
it just it was whatever she could get a
good deal on
for all you know it's gonna be fried
chicken for lunch
you know or it could have been chicken
fried steak
you don't know any of that [ __ ] didn't
matter it was all the same pretty much
anything it was all the same price and
it was a variety
so you could go and i used to stop there
for lunch you know when i was working
you could go every lunch and it would be
different
you know i mean like it rarely did it
repeat back to back day to day
now i'm talking about i guess she would
probably just go and like
like you said whatever she could get the
deal exactly on and then that's what she
would make the next day yeah she was
like that lady she was about 60
something maybe 70 yeah
she cooked so and she you know and she
knew who all her regulars were
you know friendly you know happy to see
you and [ __ ] it was kind of a small
place but you
were in and out of there fast because
all i could do is just pay
you played well yeah because they didn't
have all that [ __ ] about no [ __ ]
about ordering what do you want here
this is what you're having
like i said it's just like it's just
kind of like i don't know probably other
uh you know places around human food
here
yeah that's true even places that are
like that yeah but the thing about it is
that when you know when you're growing
up and you're a kid and it's kind of
like your
your mom or your grandma or whoever's
making the food yeah it's just kind of
like well you
eat what you're what i'm gonna give you
right and that's exactly what it was it
was home-cooked meals
yeah happened to not be in your home it
wasn't in her home either it was just in
the dam
it was in like a little strip mall yeah
you know that's good though
yeah really sounds good i could eat a
big old like plate full of
4.99 [ __ ] plate just 4.99 you didn't
work you didn't know what it was going
to be but it was going to be piled high
on a [ __ ] plate
and there might be some little side
dishes you know i mean like a little bit
of greens
yeah you know like collard greens with
the with the in the pot liquor
or it might be a little bit of peach
cobbler
you know what i mean in in a little like
a dessert that went with it
it was always different though yeah i
don't know what she could get that's
pretty she was just going for what she
could get a good deal on
that seems like a good way of uh of
running that kind of [ __ ] made good
money
yeah it didn't have a lot of overheads
with her
rent or anything it was just in a real
humble looking i mean because you could
you could kind of use that to your
advantage that
you know you just kind of like eat what
you're served you know what i mean she's
basically feeding working people they
didn't have a whole lot of money and
didn't have a whole lot of time
you know what i mean and it was just
traditional southern slash
whole food yeah but there isn't a big
difference in mississippi it's the same
thing
and like i said i'll eat pretty much
anything yeah so i don't think i would
have had a problem i'm just like yeah
whatever just give it to me
it'd be a surprise yeah all right so uh
yeah watch this movie it's on hulu
it's excellent uh i missed it don't make
the same mistake i made
but yeah it's really really really good
um so i guess that'll do it we'll have
to
watch another new movie tonight and uh
so we'll have something to talk about
tomorrow
but uh i guess that'll do it for today
uh what is today again monday okay yeah
so thanks everybody for
dropping by and we will see you guys
again tomorrow bye